[Musik]
seit 20 hindernisse zu überwinden das
höchstes 5 meter das gibt es bisher über
zwei meter mann muss dass man muss die
voraussetzungen schaffen muss die
muskulären voraussetzungen schaffen man
muss die technischen voraussetzungen
schaffen dann hat es vieles training und
dann geschafft hat ist
[Musik]
am start fehler gehabt
die trainings der letzten wochen waren
alles andere als versteht sich auf die
training abbrechen müssen jetzt die so
vor dass man tolle durch sein geld wert
und ich glaube dass man auch einmal mehr
was drauflegen können nach unserer
lassen
[Musik]
hi
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr zufrieden mit dem ersten tag des
fünfkampf feste hindernisbahn portale
vorstellen
tolle leistungen eine unfallfreie gut
aufgegangen
[Musik]
[Applaus]